one of the things we've been conscious
of as we as we went through the
discussions to plan this conference was
how do we take this abstract concept of
the open Internet the open web and and
discuss it and make it applicable to
real humans living on the ground in
communities this is a core mission of
Knight Foundation is it the core mission
of the Center for civic media not
coincidentally and so one silo where we
thought we would try to tease that have
that discussion is in the realm of
science and and thinking about the way
this open platform that we all have and
that increasingly tools like these that
we all have in our pockets and and other
tools that we can hack together
increasingly cheaply that those can be
used to by ourselves by normal human
beings often dirt than nerdier normal
human beings to to observe to measure to
map to understand what's going on in the
environment around us and in the larger
citizen science movement so today we
have four five minute talks coming up
from some of the leading organizations
in this citizen silence space as well as
one emerging one and then we'll have a
brief conversation and we really want to
again living the what's enabled by that
have a conversation with you all so I'm
gonna introduce each of them
individually and we'll come up in a
series the first is Sean Bonner
from safecast
[Music]
hi so I am going to try to jam a
45-minute talk into about 60 seconds
because John makes it seem like this was
all very well planned but we only
figured this out a few minutes ago so
very quickly the overview of what
safecast is as you guys know back in
2011 there was this huge earthquake in
Japan which triggered a leak at the
Fukushima Daiichi nuclear power plant
and resulted in all sorts of drama
surrounding that mostly because there
was no information available and people
didn't know what was going on and it
wasn't necessarily that there was
information out there that people
confined it was just that there was
nothing there nobody was paying
attention to this at all and so if a
handful of friends and I got together
and thought that perhaps we could use
our communities and skills and stuff and
help with this so we thought let's get a
whole bunch of geiger counters give them
out to people and then get those
readings and then though at least be
some sort of information but the problem
with that right away was that there were
no geiger counters available anywhere
they sold out right away
so our second plan was get duct tape
take tape a Geiger counter to a window
in a car and drive around with it taking
pictures with our iPhones that were
geotagged and then map those out so we
were able to get a ton of data with one
device although that was the worst
possible way to do it and so we came up
with the new plan and we designed a
whole platform hardware software and
data to collect this we dropped cars
people drive all around collected this
data and then we started getting a much
better picture of what was going on we
actually published the data immediately
that showed that the evacuation areas
were wrong they had to change where
people were being moved to and from
because of this and the data that we're
collecting now is all the way down to
street level as opposed to huge averages
which was the little bit that was
available before so we can get data all
the way down to an individual GPS point
anywhere in the world where we have
devices and being open giving these
devices out to people all over the place
we're getting data from everywhere so we
started this with zero absolutely no
data available and it's been climbing
pretty quickly to today right now we're
just
I have 20 million data points in 53
countries around the world it's the
largest data set of open radiation data
that's available anywhere everything
we're doing again is open so all of our
software is open source all the hardware
anybody can can go to the website get
any of it they can build these devices
themselves collect this data publish it
back to us we have a kit that's
available if people want to you know
save the time of trying to source all
the parts themselves they can grab it
from us there's over 300 of these out in
the world collecting data right now
we're building out a fixed sensor
network which is setting up an early
warning system which was something that
didn't exist at all before and hopefully
that will help and it's not just in
Japan we're doing this all over the
place again we're also now looking at
how the platform that we built for
radiation might play out into other
environmental data sources that are not
immediately apparent when you walk
outside and look so we're doing air
quality and possibly some weather and
and other things all right thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
next up from sky truth David Mann 'those
morning so I want to talk to you all
this morning about citizen science
satellites and sky true things so this
is an idea around the internet of
everything a concept that's been tossed
around quite a lot and so if we can
preserve the the DIY makerspace ethos at
the open Internet what can we do to
connect people and data and technology
to solve some of the most pressing
environmental issues of our time so
Skytree there's an environmental
organization it can be applied to many
other areas and topics but we focus on
using these technologies to look at the
human impact on planet earth a big
picture view of impacts like mining the
offshore oil drilling and oil spills
that come with that hydraulic fracturing
what the impact in the landscape looks
like so all of these issues it's a
bird's eye view
if you
if birds could fly 400 miles above the
earth 17,000 miles an hour
satellites can do that and the data that
is available from them is growing every
day
I just wanted to I'm not gonna dwell on
the technology too much but this is a
image of where we are right now at the
top of the screen
this was taken Sunday and I downloaded
it yesterday in this room for free not
only could I not have done that 20 years
ago back in the 1980s to attain this
image would have cost thousands of
dollars about forty four hundred dollars
for an image like this so not only are
the sensors and the availability the
information all these you can download
millions of images from Landsat images
from NASA you can download these for
free but the technology is also as
recently evolving that people can access
this it would have taken back in the 80s
and the 90s huge amounts of technical
experience to even know what to do with
an image and so sky truth for a while
was very much an expert of organization
we were saying here's gas drilling out
on public lands in Wyoming this is what
fragmented landscape requires but this
is just us talking and telling the world
what we see and that's very useful like
when an oil spill oil well blows out in
the Gulf of Mexico and you have millions
of gallons billing into the Gulf being
able to say in the early days on
satellite imagery that this is how big
this bill is it can't possibly just be a
thousand barrels of oil a day but again
this is all just us telling other people
what we see and really the dream for sky
true thing was that any person could get
this kind of information to know what's
happening in their place that they care
about so about a year later after the BP
spill we started with a very cobbled
together system to take geospatial data
at first it was just information from
the Coast Guard's National Response
Center these are where oil and hazardous
chemical spills are reported it's a very
clunky text-only form that gets sent out
to a bunch of emergency responders and
we said well okay we can take that data
we can stick that point on a map in a
goo
Maps that people know what that looks
like and we can put all the information
into an email and we can just send it to
initially it was just to us that we
wanted to know all right every day tell
me where I should look on satellite
images for an oil slick and then we
realized well we can turn this out to
the public we can start sending this out
so if you care about the refinery that's
next door we'll send you the
notifications when that refinery starts
leaking 200 pounds of hydrogen cyanide
every day and that has that led to added
more data into that system but we still
didn't have imagery yet we wanted people
to see what's happening on the ground
and so that led to this iteration we
started with our first real truce kite
roofing project back in August of last
year which is taking all the spatial
data for oil wells gas wells in
Pennsylvania that are going to be
hydraulically fractured and all of the
aerial imagery back to 2005 putting
those together and showing people one
well at a time and just asking them ok
we know that there's supposed to be a
well drilled here do you see a well pad
ok yes you see well pet do you see huge
waste lagoons that are holding hundreds
of thousands of gallons of a fracking
water you know there's an issue for
Public Health if you live next to one of
those so we have had several thousand
people participate in this project
hundreds of thousands of image analysis
tasks we have to have a lot of people
look at the same image so that they
don't give us a wrong answer so we
average out and take the correct answers
and this gives us the ability to look at
the bigger picture of things and in
Pennsylvania this data is going to a
public health study so are those waste
ponds a source of air contamination
working at Johns Hopkins on that and
hopefully we can expand this to other
broader issues so if you care about an
issue like oil pollution we can show you
a satellite image of of places and get
you to know what an oil slick looks like
or do you care about a place like the
Theodore Roosevelt National Park will
tell you all the imagery and all the
data that we have about that so that
people can see what's happening in the
world and that they have a part in the
science of understanding Thanks
thank you David
our next presenter is Jeff Warren from
the public laboratory of science
everyone actually don't have slides but
I have some nice pictures that are gonna
go by as I talk so this is the front
page at the public my website public lab
data or you should check it out
I guess when trying to explain what
public lab is sometimes I kind of get I
stumble on it because there's lots of
different sides of it so I've been sort
of trying to explain it in the sense of
comparing it to other things like we're
sort of like Wikipedia crossed with the
homebrew Computer Club crossed with
Greenpeace a little bit but the problem
with that I think is that each of those
leads to a different kind of
misunderstanding like people initially
think Oh Greenpeace so you're about
conservation I mean I really like whales
but but but we're organization that sort
of based environmental justice which is
more about human health than it is about
whale health so so I think that's one
misunderstanding people assume that
we're creating environmental sensors to
go out and and measure the environment
and see how the environment is doing but
actually it's more about the risks to
yourself and your family near health
that that were that were concerned about
so public lab who are we it's we're a
community of about four to five thousand
people around the world who are
collaborating to develop inexpensive
environmental modern techniques that's
sort of the Wikipedia side of it like
people upload plans designs ideas they
critique each other's work they
collaborate across continents to develop
cheap sensors and well the cheap sensors
are sort of the the leverage right that
without access to scientific monitoring
equipment you can't really you know
challenge the status quo in terms of
people's understanding of pollution
issues I think the second
misunderstanding people make is sort of
the homebrew Computer Club side of
things that that were primarily a group
that is developing technologies and that
that's that the the tools the kits those
are those are the center of public lab
and actually I would say that more than
a community that is just posting a bunch
of
online and sharing them the thing that
we as a community are most trying to
construct is actually communities of
expertise and communities of practice
themselves so the technologies will come
and go right you're gonna you're gonna a
lot of it we're basing on say to
photograph an oil spill or to measure to
measure a contaminant we're using things
like digital cameras or using webcams
are using bits and pieces that we find
those things are going to change we're
riding a lot of economies of scale using
products you buy in the store but the
thing that we're trying to build is a
community which is able to innovate
solutions to their immediate problems
people who can rely on each other who
have a sense of expertise of knowledge
of the risks that they face around their
home in their neighborhood
so I think that increasingly I'm trying
not to talk about the gadgets although
they're fun I'm trying to talk more and
more as I explain public lab about the
people who through the connections they
build in the the the problems they
tackle are actually the thing that we're
creating a public lab so the third thing
I think I guess this is sort of on the
Wikipedia side of thing is are we a
citizen science organization and I think
I guess we are but I think that the word
citizen science or the term tends to it
tends to emphasize this sense of all the
data out there being gathered into a
towards a single point it neglects the
question who is we like who is who is we
that are gathering this all and a lot of
times the answer is it's scientists so
or like sorry I got to start because I
made a Chrome extension this is you
should download it it replaces all work
instances of the word scientist on the
entire Internet with scientists with
quotation marks so go get it but but
what I'm what I'm talking about here is
that that that scientists or government
or industry they're sort of like at the
center of their respective networks
they're at the top of the pyramid you
know so citizen science often refers to
collecting vast amounts of data and
pooling it and then analyzing it but who
is actually analyzing it it's it's we're
talking about big data here right and I
think that the public lab approach
doesn't necessarily presume that we're
that we like the staff of public lab or
whatever are going to collect it
and then sort of make decisions based on
it and I think that the way that this
relates to a lot of the conversations
we've heard today yesterday in terms of
big data in terms of smart cities is
when you do that when you have this sort
of pyramidal network diagram and you
collect all the data to one point and
then you have certain sort of preferred
experts who get to sift through that
data and I'm not just talking about you
know Facebook or Google I'm talking also
about you know governments and also just
just scientist just experts people who
have the knowledge and wherewithal on
resources to do that analysis and
perhaps aren't thinking in the sense of
like a just like a decentralized
discursive public they get to make
decisions on behalf of everyone else
they get to make decisions for them
because they they have an asymmetrically
large amount of data but they're they're
not sharing the decision making process
and as you know as we in our sort of
society today we increasingly depend on
science and technology to justify
decisions and to sort of motivate good
decision-making that's a real problem
because if people aren't involved in the
analysis of the data I'm not just
talking about the collection like going
out and banding birds or or taking water
samples or whatever and that's great but
actually looking at the trends
understanding them and and inferring
things from them advocating for
different things based on the data
participating in that whole data
lifecycle past the collection point all
the way to where you say okay now we've
understood the issue
now let's as a society decide to do
something about it and decide to do this
about it and reaching consensus or or at
least reaching disagreements those are
the parts that I think are missing from
the this idea of smart cities and and
and from the sort of broader idea of big
data so I think what what public lab is
trying to do is to get people involved
in all those different parts of the data
lifecycle so it's not just about
collecting data and handing it to
someone who knows what to do with it
it's not just about getting enough data
to the right people who can make the
decisions for you it's actually about
data and participation in its production
its analysis and the advocacy that comes
after it that's something that everyone
has a responsibility to be part of in in
our democracy so I guess that's sort of
the big picture that's that's a lot of
stuff to tackle but
but I think that if you only do the
beginning or you only do the end you're
gonna miss out on what is really a
participatory form of government so
anyway that's sort of public lab in a
kind of large nutshell thank you next up
is the center for civic media's very own
Kathryn Ignacio
hi everyone Kathryn Ignacio it Center
for civic media I just want to say what
an honor it is to share the stage with a
couple of these much projects that are
much further along on their trajectory I
want to talk to you today about the Open
Water Project so we are in the very
early stages of development and we're
about making water monitoring tools
software data and education lower cost
more accessible and more public so this
is not just my project there are a lot
of really amazing people working on this
project we're being incubated by public
lab and we're developed within the
public lab community an ecosystem we
have a number of partners on the project
that include academics and hydrologist
at Plymouth State and down to
environmental advocacy organizations
like the Mystic River watershed
association and then I just want to
recognize there's a bunch of people in
the audience today that are working on
this project so Don Blair is there
Adrien Debbie Garr is there and Heather
Craig is there and so all of these
people can also talk to you about this
project and where we are so water
monitoring who cares about it right so
there are a lot of people who care about
water monitoring these are the people
that we're developing with and that
we're developing for and so just to
mention a couple of those science and
environmental journalists watershed
managers and municipal governments
hydrologist anyone working on climate
science and rising sea levels
farmers USGS and then down to
individuals and communities that are
affected by water events such as
pollutions combined sewer outflows and
things like this so our project you know
we're in the early stages and what we've
really coalesced around
sort of like Sean was mentioning is just
the set of open values so we have five
opens that we talked about so it's open
hardware open software open data open
community and open education so it turns
out that water monitoring water quality
is really complex ideally you'd have a
sensor that it would just be like good
or bad but it's way more complex than
that
there's various aspects of a water
system that you need to keep in balance
like dissolved oxygen and nitrogen you
may want to be measuring for a specific
pollutant in the system like arsenic or
mercury and then one of the most
complicated things about water of course
is that it's always changing it changes
over time it's a system it's a complex
system so rather than making a separate
test for every possible thing that you
might want to test your water system for
our approach has been to model our
hardware and our instrument after the
idea of a thermometer so the thermometer
takes your temperature and then your the
thermometer tells you you have a fever
and that there's something going on but
the thermometer doesn't diagnose you it
doesn't say like oh you have the flu or
you have a virus or something like that
researchers like Mark Greene have been
demonstrating recently how conductivity
actually can serve this purpose so
conductivity in relationship to other
measurements like temperature and depth
can show us this correlative
relationship with pollutants in the
system and so far he's been looking at
arsenic and chloride and is looking at
other pollutants as well and so this is
actually pretty exciting because what it
means is that conductivity can be an
indicator for something's wrong just the
same way that our body temperature is an
indication that something is wrong in
the body so there are water logging
technologies out there being widely used
by researchers
so these measure water data over time
these are around $1500 for measuring
which is actually not that bad but the
fact is that one in isolation doesn't
really tell you that much about a water
system so you need to deploy multiple
things of these which means that the
cost goes up so here's our initial stab
at a water monitoring system we call it
the riffle and I think Don is gonna hold
it up and maybe even like pass it
around people can take a look at it and
so the the riffle monitors conductivity
temperature and depth basically the same
thing that those commercial water
loggers are measuring for about a tenth
of the price is what we're looking at
right now so it's comprised of these a
thermistor and an audio cable which is
actually being used to measure
conductivity sticking out of the top and
then cut some circuit board but which is
based around the Arduino and then three
double A batteries which all fit in
either a typical water bottle or we're
exploring other kinds of enclosures for
them right now as well so here's you
know there's a bunch of ways you could
potentially use this so if you're
interested in monitoring downstream
pollution from a particular point like a
farm or factory you could deploy a pair
of these and be testing sort of what are
the changes in these measurements and
you could be monitoring in a private
well so you put a single one in
hopefully in conjunction with other
people in your area that are also
monitoring that or if you wanted to
measure an entire system you could
deploy a bunch of these to get a very
high spatial and temporal resolution of
data and so one of the other challenges
in the space is open software and open
data so a lot of the software systems
are proprietary the data formats are
also proprietary so we've been working
with Jeff Walker who's a postdoc out of
Tufts to think about a very simple
software platform where people using the
riffle could upload their data and share
their data across a wide network and
also discuss it and visualize it so the
open community part of this we are being
incubated through public lab and they've
been really awesome supporters of this
project and so the great thing about
working in an open community format is
just this possibility for rapid
distributed innovation so these are just
two examples of you know how things have
worked so far so like the top one is
sort of how our label design has evolved
you know one person says one thing
another person puts up another thing and
so on and so forth and then the bottom
slide here is sort of our iterative
process for developing arriving at that
insight around measuring conductivity
with an audio cable you basically need
two metal points and you need to be
measuring the voltage drop between
those across the water and so we needed
a stability of sort of points there so
we first started with this 3d printed
cap with wires we moved to a model with
two screws and then someone had this
great invention of the the audio cable
which really simplified things so in any
case these are our pilot sites and
partners that we're hoping to deploy
with and work with on the project and
then finally our model of open education
is something that we're currently
seeking funding for we want to pilot an
engagement model where we create Civic
nodes around environmental monitoring at
the watershed level so the Civic nodes
are based on this idea of creating the
time and space to bring together people
who already care and are invested in the
idea of water quality and then who can
help translate that into data collection
advocacy and storytelling to broader
publics and so we'd love to talk with
more of you about how we can engage
journalists and journalism students in
this kind of thing and anyone else who's
interested just join our mailing list on
the public web site so thanks very much
so we're gonna slowly shift the terrain
here so we can actually have a
conversation Wow well oh I just lost my
mic all right
I'll fix my mic so what we want to do oh
look at that thank you
is I'll sit down first I'm really taken
by Jeff's point around the inverted
commas for our for our European friends
the inverted common scientist so where I
want to start as folks come back on up
everyone up another round of applause
for our presenters please so I really I
do want in in Ethan is playing the role
of Phil Donahue slash Oprah today so
please and get your questions ready I
was taken with the inverted commas
scientists and and applause that got and
it raises to me the question how do you
each with your projects think about
relate to and work with existing
institutions whether it's quote unquote
real scientists or other or journalists
or just other types of institutions that
are already out in in the field doing
similar projects and how do you how do
you bridge that relationship well first
I wanted to say I like scientists my
parents are scientists I don't have any
I just it's supposed it was supposed to
as you read you know articles online to
sort of provoke you to think about who
are these experts and and what gives
them the expertise to be making these
statements about things that you care
about or that affect you so it's not
supposed to be to mean to them actually
but but I to that point actually a lot
of people in the public cloud network
our formal scientists at formal
institutions and have labs and and
sometimes they don't even say so for a
long time and then and then you know
you're you're in this long months long
conversation with them and then they
sort of mentioned oh I could just take
this to my lab at NASA
where I work and you're like you could
have done that this whole time really
but I think that they're an integral
part of this I think that there's no way
to make progress on environmental
justice you know research and and and
identifying pollutants without alliances
and without building bridges with
existing institutions and I think that
in many cases those experts are
extremely eager to work directly with
the public and on things that have an
immediate import to to you know health
and you know the neighborhoods they live
in and so forth I think with what we're
doing is we're very conscious of the
expert analysis behind everything and
we're shaping our projects around where
we know there's a need so example for
example Johns Hopkins came to us they
wanted to know where certain sources of
air contamination might be and so we
built a tool around that and quite
frankly at this point it's taken more
effort to build the public engagement
side of things then it simply would have
been to sit and intern down at a
computer and trace out all those
wastewater ponds but the idea is that by
engaging people in that and I mean
taking care of some things like
redundancy we have 10 different people
look at the same image and then we go
back and quality-control it to make sure
that what we're providing is in fact
something usable by real scientists but
we're conscious of that from what we
want people to see what we want to point
them towards yeah like Jeff because of
the open aspect of safecast we have a
lot of different people jumping in from
different places and a bunch of those
people actually get paid to do this in
in the real world so you know we have we
have scientists contributing to stuff we
feel like some of what we're doing is
science but more than that we actually
so listed as much as possible critique
on our work to make sure that it
actually holds up to any kind of
critique in that that it's useful
because we're asking people to spend
their time and effort to go out and
collect this data so that it can be used
for other things and if and if it can't
be used for those things and it's a
waste of everybody's time so if the data
doesn't hold up then there's really no
point in what we're doing so we're very
we're very interested in making sure
that our stuff fits and
and for us also building off what you
guys are saying I think where we have
sort of the real scientists or whatever
working with us as co-creators and
collaborators on this project we're
using their research in the development
of the hardware they were using the
software knowledge that has come out of
extensive experience doing water quality
monitoring we're also using the that
knowledge from Patrick Harran for
example who does water quality
monitoring and the mystic which is an
environmental advocacy organization and
so I see it more around in a sense what
our role might be is to stage encounters
between the people that have expertise
but who might be seeking a greater
component of how do you like leverage
that knowledge and get it out into the
public and then bringing together people
who have already an interest in water
and water quality monitoring for
specific sort of community-based reasons
there's like how do you stage encounters
and create space and time for those
audiences to come together and share
that knowledge I don't know I mean I
think that's that's sort of what I was
showing at the end is that the model
that we want to pilot is basically
creating a program that would be based
at the watershed level that would bring
together what we were calling these
Civic nodes which would include sort of
scientists educators the environmental
advocacy groups I mean not all of them
at the same time but like sort of these
representatives of each one at that
particular watershed level and then
journalists as well and thinking about
each of those groups has then this
broader audience that they communicate
back to to which their opinion means
something so like the academics
communicate back to an academic
community and that has a huge import for
for how knowledge gets gets gets pushed
forward but journalists communicate to
the public that has also a huge value
and bringing public attention to
something and so that's that's the thing
that we want to pilot but it's
definitely not figured out how do you
guys specifically deal with relate with
work with Ally with journalists
there was actually a discussion about a
month ago and one of the public lab
lists about you know the role of
inexpensive sensors and DIY technology
is for Environmental Research in in
journalism and it was sort of a split
crowd a lot of people you know coming
from the journalism space a lot of
people from the sort of the tech area or
that I've you know the activism side of
things people saying well you know do
journalists have the time resources to
do long-form investigative work in the
environmental space and to sort of tool
up and learn these techniques and and so
forth and a lot of people were saying
that you know that's the that's what
they have to do to you know in modern
journalism some people saying there's no
way anyone's gonna have the time or
money to pursue those things or at least
the time if the the tools are cheap but
I think that there's a lot of
opportunities for partnerships there
where journalists can get in contact
with and begin collaborating with
citizen groups who are living in the
areas that are affected that are doing
monitoring on their own and can you know
collaborate share data and they don't
necessarily have to learn how to build a
sensor or use it or whatever that they
should think of local folks as a
resource as a pool of expertise as
people who really deeply understand a
problem and are deeply invested in it
and and I think that that's that's where
the the real magic is going to happen
okay you should totally add journalists
that plays into this a lot you know I
mean given given the open piece again
everything's available for for people so
they're a little bit of how much people
are interested in being a part of it and
so we see with safecast everything from
journalists who write full stories about
what we're doing without ever speaking
to anybody and just sort of pulling
pulling little bits and pieces out of
other stories that they found around or
you know copying one line off our
website or something to people who fly
to where we're at or come visit our
volunteers that that go out in the field
with us that collect data that get one
of our own devices that see how it works
themselves and everything in between
there so I think that by making
everything available there's there's a
huge wealth of information for
journalists to take that and write very
compelling
pieces and pass that information on and
so there's a little bit a little bit of
that is more in in the hands of the
journalists whether they actually are
going to move on that or not I want to
pick on I've been looking out there on
the lights to see if Jeremy Gilbert from
National Geographic is there
I wondered Jeremy if even any slowly
wakes it makes its way back to you with
the mic or maybe you can come towards
this way so Jeremy works at National
Geographic which has done a little bit
around science and a little bit around
journalism has a hundred and thirty year
legacy in the space I'm curious to get
your reactions with your your Nat Geo
pit helmet on only 126 years so it's not
that old no I mean I think the one thing
that's really interesting that we have
spent a lot of time thinking about is
the the difference not not in who's a
scientist because I love the idea that
everyone is potentially a scientist and
everyone is collecting data and I think
you've already touched a little bit on
the analysis part of it but one of the
things that's really interesting I think
for me about the frame of National
Geographic is that we're interested in
funding science we're interested in
telling great stories and we're also
interested in education and I guess the
question I would pose to the panel
particularly is about the educational
component which is one of the things
we've run into is that data collection
is different than analysis but it's also
different than asking the questions that
each of you have asked that led to the
projects where you're collecting that
data I was wondering what you have been
able to do to start people thinking
about asking not questions of a
scientist but scientific questions
questions that can be proven proven with
your kind of data well I think that
getting at the sort of environmental
justice origins of the the work that
we're doing in the the fact that we work
with a lot of environmental justice
groups
many people actually start with the
question they don't they aren't looking
for education necessarily and education
sort of almost a byproduct because the
you know like folks in in the Gulf Coast
during the BP spill we're like well is
this are these tar balls or are they is
this organic material of some sort
what's going on here is my family safe
they have very pressing questions and
and in some cases you know they just
want an answer they don't
have to fiddle with some device or
something right but but some people I
think have the a little bit more you
know time resource and they can they can
step back and say if everyone had easy
ways to to determine these things to
identify contaminates to you know check
on these things then then we'd be in a
better position in the first place so so
I guess that's that's part of it I think
I would add that our projects and the
idea of sky true thing of putting all
this imagery and data out in front of
people is maybe in a way a subliminal
education that we want to offer an
opportunity for people to take part in
the scientific project you know
something that's an take action that's
more than just adding your name to a
petition but as they're going through
hundreds of images of well pads in state
forest land in people's farms right next
to houses that eventually sinks in that
you start to see this is all of the
impact that already exists and this is
all of the area that could potentially
be impacted in the future so I think
having people go through that process
and and learning about what things to
look for in an image is sort of a
subliminal education even if they're
just coming as a I want to take action
in some sort of area well you know with
with radiation it's a very political
topic and there's lots of hot discussion
surrounding it from all different sides
and so we try to we try to further that
conversation as much as possible without
without taking a definitive stand on it
one way or another so we have mailing
lists and and blog posts and things
where we point to people who are doing
analysis and we provide the data for
people who are doing analysis and try to
create a forum where these discussions
can come from and where people can can
look at the data and try to gather
something in truthful and interesting
from it without you know keeping the
data to ourselves and saying oh here's
what it means yeah and I just want to
say that I think that that question is
really important and I think it points
at a opportunity in this space to think
more programmatically about how
engagement happens and how education
happens and what are the
ways that people come into that I mean a
lot of times we think like it's like
it's very empowering the discourse of
citizen science and citizen journalism
are very empowering to think that like
we could all do this but then actually
getting people to that point especially
if people aren't prepared to like devote
their lives to it
is I I just think that's a whole realm
of sort of social design that we can
think together about and that's what I'm
hoping can start to emerge from all of
us working together I guess on this are
new forms of engagement models where we
think really concretely about like then
we will create this opportunity and
these couple stakeholders will be at the
table and then this thing will happen
from there where it so it's not just
about like if we put it out there but we
think really concretely about how we get
to those next steps I think we have time
for one more question
and if there's not one I want to riff
off something Kathryn and I were talking
about earlier and off of your point
right there but how we engage with other
audiences simultaneous to this
conference there's a conference taking
place right now called next library
where they're talking about the future
of libraries and how to reinvent and
rethink libraries and civic institutions
and as you heard yesterday we I think
Knight Foundation it sees libraries is
very much as a key institution for
connecting with humans where they live
in their neighborhoods and I wonder as
you think about other institutions that
the libraries or other civically based
institutions where you're most excited
where you see the greatest potential
whether it's schools or libraries or if
they're other oh yes oh I'm dumping that
real quick you know one of the one of
the things that was core to safecast
founding was was the hackerspace culture
I run a hackerspace in Los Angeles we
work very closely with a hackerspace in
Tokyo so all these hackerspaces working
together is how safecast exists so it
wouldn't it wouldn't without that
network and so I've been very excited to
see sort of the hackerspace makerspace
influx into libraries in Los Angeles one
of the main libraries in Koreatown is
going to be hosting the the la
makerspace on their whole second floor
now there's a lot of other library
systems around the country that are
working closely in putting makerspaces
and hackerspaces and fab labs and things
actually into their spaces and so I
think that giving that in from
excuse me and helping the community sort
of get more involved in that sort of
hands-on making piece of it I'm really
excited about where that's gonna head
and environmental or student groups
especially environmental student groups
on campuses that has been a great
opportunity for us we've really seen
engagement we got some people just
coming to the website organically to
look through these tools we're providing
but really sitting people down at a in a
room ordering a bunch of pizza and just
saying let's spend a couple hours and
and go through a couple thousand images
and processing that that has really
gotten people sitting her in one place
talking about an issue even if it's not
quite so creative as the hackerspace
idea it's engaged a group of people in
an event yep I know you guys you guys
have even used like public marketplaces
as places to engage people where they
are yeah I mean I think well one thing
that I guess we do a lot is we organize
in-person events all over the world and
and by we I mean like we have a fairly
large organizers network of people who
are interested not only in the
monitoring and so forth but in actually
you know creating groups of people
cultivating you know sort of local
chapters of public lab to tackle
specific problems and so the the sort of
local meetup has been a backbone of that
of that sort of growth people get
together they pitch to each other sort
of updates on projects they've been
working on they ask for help on things
people exchange tips they actually bring
devices and monitoring devices or they
ask about data they brought and there's
a real sort of important aspect to
in-person meetings and those sort of
bonds that you create in the connections
you create there we also have periodic
regional and and international events we
have that we call the barn raisings
after the Amish barn raising idea of
like coming together to make something
and typically those are done at sites
where there is environmental justice
concern the the one that we have every
year is south of New Orleans in a place
called cocoa tree and it's in a place
where you know as we're sort of enjoying
ourselves after the conference day is
and people have made a bunch of things
you can sit there and actually see a
refinery flare you know a mile down the
road you can see a lot of the hardware
from the oil and gas operations in the
area out in the in the wetlands as
you're canoeing around there and I think
that that sort of immediacy of the
issues that people face and inspires and
sort of keeps people focused on those
sorts of problems as opposed to just
making stuff but it's sort of a hybrid
of us kathan what's the next place that
you're excited about engaging people we
were so excited about the library at the
Chicago Libraries News Challenge winner
so we've been talking a lot about that
actually I think that's a great way to
end thank you please give a round of
applause for our presenters here today
[Applause]